avant de commencer l'émission j'aurais
voulu dire quelques mots parce que je me
suis clairement posé la question de ma
participation à cette émission ce soir
en raison de l'ouverture d'une enquête
par la justice à la suite d'une plainte
déposée contre monsieur bourdin on
attend vos messages vos commentaires vos
réactions ça fait qu'on lit tout même
les pires insultes donc n'hésitez pas si
vous me détestez twitter facebook
instagram et les sms aux 41,5 5,5
british a généralement n'a que des
intérêts vous aime c'est de la
manipulation
manipulation mentale en tant que pervers
narcissique alors je sais qu'il conteste
fermement c'est fait et bien sûr c'est à
la justice de les trancher et je
respecte la présomption d'innocence à
laquelle chacun de nos compatriotes alto
3 mais je voudrais le dire très
clairement je dois le dire très
clairement si ces accusations sont
avérées elles sont graves et elles
doivent être condamnés peut-être que
vous aussi vous avez déjà reçu des émaux
j dans des messages qui ne vont pas du
tout avec la conversation vous êtes en
train d'avoir ça a été mon cas quand un
membre de ma famille m'a envoyé à
plusieurs reprises un emoji dans visage
petit sourire en coin en l'occurrence
cette personne a été mon père il pensait
que ça voulait dire je suis très content
alors que non pas du tout cette énergie
est utilisée dans des contextes un petit
peu sulfureux des contextes de flirt
pour voir de gros sous entendu je
voudrais ajouter les répètes caire
pécresse j'ai décidé de ne pas
m'exprimer à ce sujet mais je conteste
les faits rapportés par la presse et je
laisse la justice faire son travail
c'est désormais ce sont les internautes
vous savez qui décide ce qui est bien de
faire ou non dans la vie c'est devenu
une sorte de tribunal je prends pour
exemple la dernière photo postée par
david beckham avec sa fille regardez
bien est ce que quelque chose vous
interpelle sûrement sur la bouche oui
non oui semble maintenant qu'ils
absolument ben en fait il embrasse sa
fille de 10 ans et forcément vous allez
me dire où est le problème c'est quoi le
problème en fait pour une multitude de
gens cette photo montre le caractère
pervers de david beckham
alors benjamin c'est vrai que ce sujet
pour tout ça mais après il ya parfois
des produits suite expérience et tout
conflit qui est
surprenant c'est récent sévriens surtout
qu'en plus dans les téléspectateurs
n'ont pas d'odeur mais
avant que jimmy jimmy c'est bien
williams est ce que ça choquerait qu'on
fasse tous les deux une photo similaire
ah oui oui oui non mais hélas je ne suis
pas votre fille assez dommage ça s'est
ajouté
rions un peu avec nicolas dupont aignan
qui sort le stand-up son nouveau sketch
est génial dans l'obs le candidat à
l'élection présidentielle d'éclat en
fait quand on y réfléchit je suis un
meilleur candidat de second tour que
deux premiers tours
si la chute le problème c'est qu'il faut
accéder à ce second tour s'est montré
qu'on soit pour le moins lucide jean
michel blanquer à ibiza lorsqu'il
annonce le nouveau protocole sanitaire
un timing qui ne passe pas auprès des
syndicats d'enseignants dont le snalc
les personnels de l'éducation nationale
en manquant même ras-le-bol du manque de
respect le problème c'est pas tant
qu'ils aient été à tel endroit plutôt
qu'à tel autre le problème c'est que on
a eu à appliquer un protocole de lundi
de la rentrée qu'on a découvert le
dimanche soir dans un article payant
depuis hier soir les masques ffp2
réclamé par les professeurs ont une
autre allure
et l'on imagine les réunions hommes du
ministre au bord de l'eau
alors c'est très tentant de lui imaginer
danser dans une boîte mais je rappelle
qu'elles sont fermés et surtout qu'on
parle de jean michel blanquer le truc le
plus déglingo qu'il a dû faire et ibis
assez des mots fléchés force 4 et boire
une tisane lui tranquille donc on les
imagine mal comment on pourrait dire ça
quand on l imagine mal comment le dire
poliment
je crois que jean michel blanquer la
partie n'a pas pour pour frétiller de la
fait cependant si des manifestants sont
have a brûlé dépasse sanitaires certains
primo vacciner appels à brûler leurs
passes un acte symbolique qui vise à
dénoncer le chantage des libertés et ces
mesures toujours plus restrictives qui
n'en finissent plus ce nouveau pack back
sénat prévoit d'octroyer le droit au
contrôle d'identité pour ceux qui
douteraient de l'authenticité du baas
ouais savoir si vous avez fait des tests
qu vide ah oui on a fait pas mal de
tests coville ouais on est on était
alors maintenant bon on essaie de faire
attention comme tout le monde j'ai envie
de dire mais avant la mission vous
encore plus attention tout ce qu'on
voulait pas mettre en danger la mission
en fait attraper le coc vie d'avant et
puis du coup retardé annulé le décollage
ou encore pire emmenez le locaux vides à
bord de la station spatiale pour les que
les collègues qui étaient déjà là bas
donc on fait très attention moi j'ai
fait 49 j'ai décompté test pc avant le
décollage ouais bah tiens je vais le
faire symbolique
demain pas parce qu première chance
clock obligés de faire des passes et là
je vous lance un message moi je vous
lance un message ça c'est la flamme de
la liberté j'espère qu'on va retrouver
nos libertés pour nous et nos enfants
voyez c'est symbolique mais moi je le
fais devant vous monsieur j'ai grandi
c'est un beau message qui est passé
et
[Musique]
des tons tour noire qui étaient là
habillé un peu avec de la peau ou un
truc comme ça et de relais t elle était
dans une marmite et il allait la manger
tout ça et où je regarde satin jan 10
ans et en 9 ans je vois tu as honte un
peu quoi tu le dis mais ça c'est nous ça
qui va vraiment trop loin abusif
une jeune professeur de svt a été
exfiltré d'un établissement près de
paris son tort avoir voulu expliquer la
théorie de l'évolution en utilisant
votre photo pour illustrer l'homo
sapiens après avoir constaté que les
manuels scolaires ne mettait en scène
que des hommes blancs elle a décidé
d'utiliser votre photo et ce depuis
plusieurs années depuis 2015 quelle est
la poupée la moins jolie
[Musique]
la loire est ce que j'aime pas trop lire
pourquoi
parce que tous les enfants de l'école et
soul blanche et moi quand je serai grand
je mettrais tu les as créé pour devenir
blanche
mais en décembre 2020 un papa partage le
cours sur l'évolution sur les réseaux
sociaux elle est accusée de racisme
cette femme est victime de raids
numérique d'une vague de haine et
surtout de menaces de mort la pauvre la
police lui conseille de quitter l'île de
france et notamment des vignes ou encore
sous le choc de l'assassinât terroristes
de samuel pâtit le père famille qui a
partagé le document sur internet et
qu'on a été condamné à six mois de
prison ferme madame c votre fille vous
annonçait qu'elle peut épouser un noir
qu'est ce que vous lui diriez pas je lui
dirai que
y a des plans quand même sur la terre je
voudrais pas que mon fils ait pas une
loi pourquoi robert pascaud café olé olé
de la djs pour aller à vau biscotte
c'est quoi une biscotte je sais moi
j'aimerais dire ça ah bon mais c'est nul